the asean has rejected the government's
payoffer and they plan to escape strikes
now we know you don't want them to
strike but I just want to start by being
clear about how high you think the
stakes here are
well I think the lives are going to be
lost as a consequence of this strike
well I think it would be a serious
strike and it will be a challenge but
can I just pick you up on one thing the
RCN leadership effectively recommended
the payoffer it's the RCN membership
that voted narrowly to reject it there
are still other unions that are out
there still balloting at the moment
Unison the largest Health Service Union
which represents I think a third of all
agenda for change staff that's the staff
affected has voted in favor so let's
wait and see where the other ballots
come in yeah what uh you're right about
the size of Unison but that represents
all uh Health Service staff as you say
but there are half a million nurses who
have voted narrowly or not they have
voted to reject the offer and I really
want to just get started by being clear
about what we think the cost of this
might be especially if it is a escalated
into what is now being called the mega
strike where several different disputes
coordinate to strike on the same day
Junior doctors and so on and so forth
how serious do you think this is going
to be well look I think the public uh
very concerned understandably and we
will do everything that we can and I'm
sure the NHS management the NHS will do
everything that it can to make sure that
uh that the impact of the strike is kept
under control but I I wouldn't be being
truthful if I didn't say it will have an
impact a nurse is going on strike it
will clearly have an impact but we think
that we've made a fair and reasonable
offer four percent last year five
percent this year plus lump sum payments
starting at 1 250. that is why the RCN
leadership and Unison and other unions
have actually recommended this offer to
their memberships but let's be clear you
are not going to do anything
further on the offer to avert a possible
strike you are not budging that's your
fight that's a full and final offer it
is a full of Vine level but we are
waiting for the other results to come in
from the other unions let's say Unison
the Lord
when you say you're waiting for the
others to come in does that do you mean
you're waiting for the others to come in
because what you might do depending on
the results of the GMB ballot and so on
you might decide to vary the offer or
are you just hoping that the others will
vote to accept the offer and the RCN
will be isolated which one is it well
it's it is a full and final offer but
equally it's only reasonable for us
we've been accepted uh the offer has
been accepted by Unison recommended by
the RCM but not accepted by its
membership is only reasonable for ours
during the middle of the balancing
process to wait to see those further
results and we'll be laying out a
response will obviously meet meeting
with the NHS staff unions as well to
make sure that we can take that forward
but the position is that we're waiting
to see what the other results are at the
moment and we just urge everybody this
is a very very reasonable offer it's
fair to it's fair to NHS workers it's
fair to other public sector workers and
it's fair to the taxpayer so just to be
absolutely clear and I don't want to say
that what you said is interesting
because what you'll immediately do is
say no I didn't say that but what I hear
here is a government that says
this is our full and final offer
in a new situation there may be more
talking to be done well look Steve
Barkley has said that his door is always
open uh
um so long as in particular answered a
preconditions or strikes taking place
you know we are willing to talk but this
has been something which has been
thrashed out with the unions themselves
this four percent then five percent
offer 1 250 minimum folks it's a very
very reasonable offer Trevor so both you
um both you under the the rtn leadership
clearly misjudged the temper of the
members but what I'm hearing you saying
here is that the government is not set
in concrete it is willing to talk
depending on what the broad uh the broad
set of results in these ballots we're
all turned out to be I mean Steve
Barkley is always willing to talk so
long as there aren't preconditions
attached and so long as there isn't the
threat of strikes going on at the moment
uh but as I say this is a fair and
reasonable offer
um that has been accepted by Unison as
being balloted by others has been
accepted by Unison represent okay third
of the agenda for change staff I mean
it's a big part of it all right look
um
Rishi sunak was supposed to be all about
quiet effective Administration getting
stuff done
um but now we've got doctors and strike
nurses on strike civil servants
balloting teachers balloting again rail
workers out there walking off the job
um now what all these outfits have in
common is that they are ultimately in
the pay of the government it doesn't
really Inspire confidence when your own
employees basically are walking off the
job well I don't agree with that I think
Rishi sunak is doing a very good job
overall he's laid out his uh five
priorities of halving inflation uh
cutting the debt growing the economy
reducing Hospital waiting is stopping
the boats those are the people's
priorities that is what Rishi sunak is
getting on with I'm letting you repeat
the slogan but my point is you're not
going to be able to do any of that if
all your employees are out on strike and
here's your problem
parents can't be sure that schools are
going to be open commuters can't be sure
that there's going to be a train that
gets them to work the patients can't be
sure they'll get their operation we pay
our taxes to make sure that you the
government keep these basic Services
going and frankly yeah I know you want
to say it's somebody else's fault but
actually that's what we pay you for and
you're not doing the job why shouldn't
we vote for you in a couple of weeks
time because I think the government is
delivering on overall where the people
want us to be delivering on it's
obviously difficult times no one's
pretending this job is in any way easy
the inflation that has been Unleashed by
Vladimir Putin's illegal and appalling
invasion of Ukraine again you're blaming
this on Vladimir Putin well I'm blaming
inflation Vladimir Putin didn't vote in
the ballot it's your negotiation or
failure I'm blaming Vladimir Putin and
the increase in Energy prices which is
what has driven inflation in the first
place that is why inflation is such a
high priority for the government the
halving inflation is absolutely one of
our five priorities that is if you like
the backdrop for why there are
increasing pay demands is to keep Pace
with inflation and the inflation is
obviously driven the UK is not alone in
this our inflation rate is it is other
countries are also facing very high
inflation similar issues with uh let's
just give this one more go the nurses
did not declare war on Ukraine the
teachers haven't negotiated the rise in
oil on on in Energy prices this is
supposed to be your job and all of the
people
that you pay who you employ basically
are cross with you let's put it that way
and they are walking oh good job but
that's a failure of you as an employer I
don't agree with that Trevor actually
because when you look at uh what's going
on in the NHS for example uh there's six
unions at the moment balancing as I
already mentioned Unison which
represents uh the largest part about a
one-third of the agenda of a change
staff their members have accepted
there's other uh unions balloting at the
moment the RCN leadership implicitly
recommended the offer so the the
position or the situation is much more
nuanced than you are than you are
suggesting that actually the government
is delivering we're delivering what I
think are fair offers uh to public
sector workers a four percent last year
five percent this year in the case of
NHS staff minimum payments one one-off
lump sum payment of at least 1 250
pounds that I think most people out
there will agree is a reasonable I've
gone over that but I mean I would say
that you're also delivering uh late
train and school closures uh and also uh
delayed appointments and operations and
that's your responsibility not everybody
else well it's our one of our priorities
is to get to grips with the NHS waiting
list and you're right that the strikes
do not make it any easier Bringing Down
the NHS waiting list but nonetheless
that is what we are fixed on that is
what Steve Barkley that's what the prime
minister is fixed on is one of the five
priorities reducing NHS waiting lists
we're treating her
um has said this morning uh to us that
he thinks that effectively the RCN are
in the wrong
in their decision not to provide cover
for emergencies uh do you agree with him
well look I think we'd like to see uh
the management of the NHS make sure that
the impact of the strike be effectively
made as as as as minimal as it can be
notwithstanding this will have will have
an impact
um but we're relying on the management
there to deliver a good program of care
they're not willing to say that this is
an ethically a wrong thing to do well
it's it's my job is to at the moment I'm
waiting to see the results of the other
ballots yeah I'm not getting into
criticizing specific people how they
behave and one trying to get a
resolution and Steve Barkley and the
Prime Minister trying to get a
resolution to this dispute but as I say
we're waiting for the other ballot
results to come in all right well very
diplomatic let's talk about the other
big news from this week um
presence Biden's brief visit to Belfast
um the dup leader to Jeffrey Donaldson
said it doesn't change the political
dynamic in Northern Ireland we know what
needs to happen and he is not going back
to Stormont
um so what's the point of this visit
well I think the point of the visit was
to recognize
um 25 years the anniversary of the
brilliant Good Friday agreement that's
why Rishi sunak was in Belfast then as
well was to recognize what has been an
anniversary which has delivered a lot
for the people of Northern Ireland
obviously we want to see the power
sharing government executive back in
place in Stormont as soon as possible
we've done what I think is a really good
deal on the Windsor framework to solve
that issue of the flow of goods from
Great Britain to Northern Ireland a very
pragmatic uh solution-based approach
from Rishi soon like finding solutions
to problems getting a good negotiation
good relationship with both the European
Union and with President Biden Amber the
Irish government that is where the
solution lies okay but the dup isn't
going back you need the Stormwind
assembly up and running because there
are issues in education there are issues
in health and all of that's got to be
dealt with
when you get about to the inevitable and
either opt for direct rule or fresh
elections well you can't keep sitting
forgive me on your hands and saying oh
something's going to happen you've got a
responsibility to the people of Northern
Ireland we do have a responsibility to
people in Northern Ireland and the
people of Northern Ireland very much
need the um government installment to be
back up and running and the dup to
re-enter government that is what the
government our government is urging
everybody to do to come back together
the Windsor framework we think offers a
very good and workable solution to many
of the issues that have been raised now
is the time to get a devolve government
back up and running but that's work in
progress all right let's talk about your
pledges and the big one there is stop
the boats
um the Home Secretary was on this
program recently and she said uh this I
think we're making tangible process in a
short period of time but ultimately yes
you'll judge us on our record
uh let's have a look at her record
um she says Judge Me by my record I'm
I'm going to ignore the stream of horror
that's emerging from our police forces
at the moment and just focus on
immigration
um prime minister stop the boat but
there's still thousands across making
the crossing each week there is a deal
with Albania but there have been almost
no illegal Crossing uh migrant from
Albania returned to to Tirana nobody has
been put on a plane to Rwanda anytime uh
so far and that's not going to happen
anytime soon unless you can tell me
differently tomorrow
um if you are judging the Home Secretary
what would you be getting this morning D
plus maybe well first of all Trevor
there have been returns to Albania yeah
tiny numbers well we're we're talking
about 15 000 people who've crossed and
the numbers are handfuls come on well
we're getting on with that and the agree
agreement with Albania of course was
only signed relatively recently but
working with Albania It's a combination
driver taking the sort of tough action
the legislation going through Parliament
which labor and the other opposition
parties have opposed at every point to
make sure that we've got the laws in
place to deal with the boats we've got
the agreement with Rwanda that is
working its way through there's been
appeals in the courts to try and stop
that we're working through those appeals
we've got the agreement with Albania
we've got the agreement with France
again set by a much better relationship
between Rishi sunak and the French
President Emmanuel macal we've got the
agreement with Rwanda we are getting on
with it but you know it is work in
progress again
there's a lot of work here for lawyers
aren't aren't there and there's a lot of
paper shuffling uh moving between here
and there the one thing that isn't
moving is uh illegal migrants back to
where they came from well that that is
why we're putting through the
legislation that's why we're reaching
these agreements with friends and allies
as diverse as Albania France Rwanda it's
actually really getting the government
getting to grips with this issue which
is exactly what we're doing both British
sunak and well look I mean don't take my
word for it let's look at what the
country uh thinks
um when soiler Brotherman first came to
office in September last year
um 76 of the public thought you're doing
a bad job
today in spite of all you've done
telling me about you know the agreement
you've made and all the rest of it
83 of the public think you're doing an
atrocious job you are the party chair
um you need to do something don't you I
mean isn't it time to put soella bravn
out of her misery reshuffle her to
somewhere else not at all not at all
she's doing a very good job and it is a
bank 83 don't agree with you okay but
what people have spoken but I've already
outlined Trevor how we're getting to
grips with the job and how we are
passing the legislation how we are
coming to these agreements with key
allies but sometimes these things will
take time and that is why for example we
are starting returns to Albania we are
getting into grips about it and Sue Ella
is right on top of it all right all
right well look um
you know the Judgment isn't mine and it
isn't yours the judgment is going to at
least or some part of the judgment is
going to be made in less than 20 days
time when you are sending your troops
into a local election uh ballot
um here is the the national picture of
voting intention and I think what it
will show us is that there is a pretty
consistent uh lead for labor of course
it's been coming off the boil recently
you can I know you'll tell me that and
so on but this is pretty awful for you
isn't it well no one was pretending it's
going to be easy last year was a very
difficult year for the country a
difficult year for the government a
difficult year for the conservative
party but what we are doing is Trevor is
getting on with the five priorities of
halving inflation restoring growth
cutting the debt reducing Hospital
waiting lists and stopping the boats
that is those are the people's
priorities those are Rishi sunax
priorities in terms of the local
elections these before principally on
local issues we've got some there's a
huge number of conservative councilors
up for re-election uh in a few weeks
time uh the conservatives Remain the
largest party of local government the
independence expectations are that labor
the conservatives will lose more than a
thousand seats and that labor need to
make big gains that is what the
expectation is out there okay but I've
been up and down the country because
they're fighting really hard I've got
some great counts you're predicting a
thousand seat loss are you just trying
to massage our expectations here that is
what the independent experts professors
Rollings and Thrasher John Curtis are
all predicting I'm saying we are
fighting really hard we've got some
great counselors great Council
candidates up and down the country have
been traveling up and down the country
the last couple of weeks all the way
from Ramsgate to Hartlepool from
Pickerington to to Worcester campaigning
okay I've let you do that but um this is
odd you're a thousand seats and you see
them rather sanguine about that
um that sort of shellicking in the past
usually leads to a sacrifice of some
kind and the prime candidate is always
the party chairman
um
after local elections uh
are you going to be the person who's
going to come in and defend the tonking
that you will have had still do you
think or will Mr sunac move you on but
let's see Trevor but what I would say is
that those are those are the independent
predictions from the uh the most
credible academic sources that the
conservatives are likely to lose a
thousand seats I'm campaigning really
hard I've got some brilliant counselors
and great candidates about fighting this
is really saying conservative Council
this is really peculiar if I were a
Conservative candidate in those
elections watching this program now and
I hope that they they all are I'd be
expecting a bit of Boris johnsonism here
I'd be expecting you to say we'll be out
there we'll be uh eating into Labor's
campaign but there's no this thousand
seats uh that that they're gonna gonna
lose it's all nonsense we are on but
you're telling them you know what it's
going to be pretty awful no I'm telling
I'm telling them because I've been
meeting with them seeing them up and
down the country in recent weeks that
actually the conservatives are fighting
hard conservative councils deliver
better they cost you less tax 80 pounds
less tax on council tax delivering
better Services better pot better action
on potholes lower crime in conservative
areas these are all kind of real
tangible deliveries by conservative
councils councilors Council Canada can I
just ask you one one last quick quick
Point
um
I'm sure that inside conservative buddy
headquarters uh you are you know you're
lowering our expectations but I think uh
you're detecting some signs of Hope in
Nepal
um
help
if the former prime minister's Boris
Johnson and Liz truss who have been
making speeches defending their records
uh recently uh would you welcome a
period of Silence from both of them well
actually in the conservative party we're
the most important thing is getting on
with the job of governance rather than
um kind of these uh um Westminster sort
of political machinations that is what
Rishi sunak is is focused on he has
focused on the five priorities that we
laid out earlier this year delivering on
those five priorities okay well that
sounds to me like a clear message to Mr
Johnson mistrust take a holiday uh Greg
hands thank you very much